one thing you and i both have in common
is we both have
famously beautiful hair and
um but mine has become
very unkempt and ragged during
the quarantine yours looks beautiful and
i understand that you're
quite good at taking care of your own
hair that you have
uh you know your talented hair stylist
is that true i
am a closet hairdresser that sounds
wrong but you know what i mean
and throughout lockdown i put the
designated hair
cutter not that that's the right phrase
either
but i had to use kitchen scissors
because we didn't have proper scissors
but i gave
some pretty epic cuts to people and i've
always cut my own
fringe and bangs i should say i could do
a bit of that with a scissor
if i i could do yeah that thing when
they
twist it around and they go
i've when i've grown my hair very long
um they do that sometimes to give it a
little twist at the bottom
give it a little like lightness on the
ends yeah
the um you know i think it's a
it takes a lot of trust to let someone
i mean i don't even trust professionals
to get near my hair
but i would trust you you know i i
i think i i would trust you i feel like
i know you
um and i would let you cut my hair
someday
if that were something you were
interested in so how about when this
whole
[ __ ] show ends um i could come and give
you a cut
are you referring to my show or the
court or the quarantine epidemic
the world and the covey restrictions
when it's over live on air because
you've now pledged that you would let me
so i'm gonna hold you to it yeah i will
i will fly to london uh to see you
because i think any man would i will fly
to london to see you
and uh you will cut my hair we'll shoot
it for the show
and then um and then i'll sue you and
we'll both be suing each other for a
while
and we'll be in the courts we could get
them to fly us to an exotic location
yes yes
haircut it's gonna be a straight down a
lockdown special
i love that on have a reality show
and screw ugg because we'll be making so
much money that way
yeah and it'll be great i you know it
will be it'll be a version of love
island only just where you
where you cut my hair obviously
there's absolutely no sexual tension i
mean there is on my part but not
on your part and it's it's a version of
love island that
isn't quite as saucy as love island
that's what we'll do
it'll be quite lady macbeth i'll creep
up with scissors all
the time of the day and it's just us on
an island and one pair of says
is what will happen and then a lot of me
and the confessional
with ragged looking hair saying she did
it again i was sleeping
sienna came in she chunk she cut off a
chunk on this side